[Music]
there's a saying long attributed to the
playwright george bernard shaw that
youth is wasted on the young
and while shaw may not have said those
exact words the sentiment they convey
the the longing to preserve the vitality
of youth is
just about as old as our ability to
write about it
2500 years ago the great greek
chronicler herodotus wrote of remote
villages whose populists bathed in
special waters and lived to be 120 and
across the ages the legend of such a
fountain of youth persisted it may be in
fact that the spanish settlement of
florida was an unintended consequence of
juan ponce de leon search for such a
fountain somewhere in the caribbean
now a cursory look at florida's
population suggests that the search has
yet to succeed but today
the search for a metaphorical fountain
of youth has the weight of science
behind it and we can see the results
medical and public health advancements
over the past century have helped to
double life expectancy now
how much farther can we go a world in
which middle age refers to someone who
is 100 or 150 a world in which the human
health span is nearly as long as the
human lifespan
a world in which aging can be slowed or
even reversed a world that is in which
the human lifespan might be virtually
unlimited suggesting that we might be
among the last human generation to have
such a pitifully short lifespan
joining me today are four leading
researchers who are making extraordinary
contributions to understanding what
makes us age and who in various ways are
developing treatments that could help
mitigate reverse and prevent the impact
of aging
[Music]
our first guest is near barzillai who is
the founding director of the institute
for aging research director of the
nathan shock center of excellence in the
basic biology of aging and also the paul
f glenn center for the biology of human
aging research at the albert einstein
college of medicine at the montefiore
health system he directs
the longevity genes project which
studies over
750 centenarians he joins us from his
home in new york
welcome near
and our next guest is alyssa epple who
is a professor as well as the vice chair
of the department of psychiatry at the
university of california san francisco
she's the president of the academy of
behavioral medicine research and his
co-author along with nobel prize winning
author elizabeth blackburn of a
best-selling book called the telomere
effect she joins us from san francisco
welcome alyssa
our next guest is laura niedenhoffer who
is the director of the institute on the
biology of aging and metabolism at the
university of minnesota where she is
also a professor of biochemistry
molecular biology and biophysics prior
to that she was at the scripps research
institute where she helped developed a
new class of drugs which selectively
kill senescent cells which are key
drivers of aging she joins us from her
office in minneapolis welcome
laura and finally our last guest is
david sinclair who's a professor of
genetics and co-director of the paul f
glenn center for biology of aging
research at harvard medical school where
he directs his own lab
he is the author of a best-selling book
entitled lifespan why we age and why we
don't have to he joins us from boston
welcome david
and
welcome to you all i want to begin with
a question that i would love all of you
to just quickly briefly weigh in on
you all are pioneers right in various
aspects of the science of aging
longevity so just to get a feel for
where you come down your thinking about
the subject do you see aging as some
kind of um inevitable wearing down that
sooner or later
everybody has got to face
or is aging really something better
thought of as a an affliction
a malady that maybe really can
be conquered so near where do you come
down on that oh i wish you asked david
first because
aging
is the mother of all diseases aging
drives all those diseases that we don't
want to get you know cancer alzheimer's
diabetes cardiovascular disease
it's the cause of that
and so in a way aging is a disease and i
i don't think we should ex
accept it
um
as much as we don't accept of having
alzheimer or any one of those diseases
the thing that david and i don't agree
about is whether
we should fight to make aging a disease
or we can find a way to deal with it as
a disease without calling it that way
for for reasons that are totally not
scientific for reasons of how do we
bring coalition
to allow us to target aging and delay
all those diseases
and stop them and maybe
reverse them so david what's your your
view of that then in response to new
year's view so i'm very much of the
belief that at least within science and
between scientists that we should regard
aging as a medical condition if not a
disease and the world health
organization has agreed with me
but i think we have to ease people into
it because it is a shock to think of
aging as something we can address
potentially with a pill or changes in
lifestyle
but i think that is it's an important
point that we can
slow aging and even potentially reverse
it with the kind of discoveries that
have been made recently and in that way
we can we will be able to treat aging
and prevent it the same way we do with
cancer heart disease and alzheimer's
that's hugely exciting and optimistic
yeah go ahead can i can i talk about
easing it okay about the concept of
using it why do we need to ease it
because the elderly who we want to help
right they don't want to be called sick
the arp their main organization doesn't
want to call aging disease american
federation of aging research doesn't
want to call aging disease but most
important fda okay we need the fda
so that we can purpose drugs to target
aging they don't want to call aging a
disease and we found out that we don't
need to you know we're going to give a
treatment that prevent age-related
diseases this is fine for now so i think
this is the easing part
of that but if we just come out today
and say let's call aging a disease we're
not going to have the coalition that we
need
in order to come from the promise to to
the realization of that well okay
so
i think all of us probably agree that
biological aging underlies disease it's
the precursor of most diseases
and so
it is true that the target of our
efforts should be slowing biological
aging it is a natural process that is
inevitable and we have some control over
that process we can slow it we can
compress disease toward the end of life
and die of old age in a healthy high
functioning way or of diseases that last
very short periods and that is about
healthy aging and a long health span but
to say you know it's a disease that
means it's something we can eradicate
and it's and it's
it's something that shouldn't happen and
that's just to me ridiculous laura
i agree with alyssa it just i think of
aging as
it's going to happen it's a natural
process it
and it's just a slow decay of your
ability
to
fix things correct things get back to
even keel and i come at this from
studying repair mechanisms within a cell
and they fail after a while and we see
this all the time as we measure what we
call the the pillars of the biology of
aging and so i think of it as pretty
much inevitable but very much modifiable
and that's what we're excited about well
let's get into some of the details then
and see where we can come down on these
various perspectives so near you spend
time
studying i guess what you call or the
field called super agers people who are
well above 100 years old
a large group of them some like more
than 700 or so isn't that right in your
study and and obviously the question is
is there some commonality between these
people is it the case that for instance
they're eating really well
dieting exercising getting all the
amount of sleep that medical science
says that we should is that what the key
to the super agers is
so that's a fascinating
question and my answer
is going to shock people because i'm
going to tell you no there is no effect
on the environment on 100 years old okay
but
and in fact you know 60 of the men
and 30 percent of the women were heavy
smoker more than 50 of them are obese
and overweight
uh exercising less than 50 even doing
housework or walking or biking and
vegetarians are only 2 but this is the
point this is true to them
because actually what they have they
have longevity what we call longevity
genes that slows their aging process and
therefore
they can do things longer i mean i don't
want anybody to say oh the secret to
longevity is not what i'm doing i should
be more obese i should smoke that's not
the case that's the case for them we do
find
specific longevity genes we find some
that are more public and some that are
more a private and actually two of those
genes have been already
used
to have a treatment
you know when we find genetic
signals it doesn't mean that we have to
have genetic
changes
it just means that this is the mechanism
and we can develop a drug and two drugs
have already been
established based in part on our
centenarians and so these longevity
genes presumably they're different from
the absence of negative genes bad genes
genes that would code for the kinds of
diseases that we usually associate with
old age is that is that correct so
that's another surprise and it's a great
question we
when we started i'll give you this
example when we had our 44 centenarians
that had the whole their whole genome
sequence okay so we had no control just
centenarians and we asked
do they have those bad genes for
alzheimer for diabetes for everything
else and we found they had on average
five to six genotype that should have
made them sick
okay there there's a database that said
those variants will probably make you
sick
and and for example
they had strong that we have two men
that have strong genetics for
alzheimer's what's called the apoe4
homozygosity
that
they should be demented at 70 and dead
at 80 and they were not demented at 100.
so
they can harbor
very bad genotypes because they have
genes that slows their aging enough to
delay for enough time or totally prevent
those diseases it's amazing alyssa you
also study
genetic
characteristics telomeres which
certainly were i remember there's a
period when they were in the news all
the time
described as sort of the the genetic
marker of aging can you tell us about
telomeres their relevance to aging yes
um absolutely i have been studying them
for several um
almost two decades now
um i do just want to add i do really
appreciate david's view of you know
of think of eradicating aging because it
pushes the envelope because it it really
creates excitement and funding for
anti-aging mechanisms and drugs and it's
it's a really exciting field and and and
that idea
is um extremely motivating to people so
david i didn't mean to come down too
hard on the aging is a disease idea
right that's okay
we'll get back to that so um
telomeres
i have studied them as a window into
rate of aging
and
laura mentioned the hallmarks of aging
there are many
interrelated mechanisms of aging and
some are more important than others
they're more
uh you know in a in a network they are
uh powerful nodes
and so
but they're all it there it's a cell
system that's regulated and they're
talking to each other so mitochondria
are one of the mechanism and they're
talking to telomeres and they really
are intertwined in their health they go
down together into dysfunction or they
stay healthy together
and what laura studies the the house
cells become senescent and stick around
is probably one of our most
biggest clues and powerful nodes to
aging and telomeres fit into that
pathway so telomeres protect the genome
they're non-coding base pairs in every
cell that protect our chromosomes but
they're highly regulated and so when
they
get too short the cell can go into cell
cycle arrest
and it can also die
um but most commonly it becomes an old
senescent cell when the telomeres start
screaming out signals if we're too short
watch out we could become a cancer cell
it becomes
a
you know kind of a non-functioning
senescent cell that secretes
inflammation and of course i want to
hear this
from our expert um laura about what
senescence looks like as a pathway for
aging so telomeres are part of that
they and where where are they on the
chromosomes so they're at the tips of
the chromosomes
and they're very very um small part
but very important
and they respond to the signals in the
cell in the blood that's in the cell and
i'm going to talk about stress in a very
general way so signals that indicate
intracellular stress are talking to the
telomere maintenance system telomeres
are maintained by telomerase an enzyme
that protects them and when there's a
lot of
glucocorticoids around this is impairing
the telomerase activity so it can't keep
the telomere long stable and healthy and
it also creates a lot of reactive oxygen
species
both directly and through the
mitochondria
and so this can lead to short telomeres
to the extent we get telomere
dysfunction a critical shortness and
what we know in humans is that in many
population studies
if you have average short telomeres in
your blood you are more likely to
develop diseases early in life and to
die earlier so they're very reliable
but small predictors in humans we know
exactly their mechanism
they they lead to replicative senescence
to cells not being able to keep dividing
but they are just one part of this
network they're an important part of
this network of aging i mean do we find
i mean going back to near's work do you
find that in the super agers
do they have longer telomeres is it a
direct association of that sort is it
much more complex
yeah we publish that
our centenarians have longer telomeres
than uh 80 years old
their children also have longer
telomeres than age match control
and we even found
a some genetic association
with the system that regulates a
telomere length which is the telomerase
system so that we do have evidence but i
have to tell you the causation
has not been established in you you know
i think that as as you started saying
it's a biomarker it's more of a
biomarker of aging i think it's clear
that when you have longer telomeres by
the way not too long because they are
risk for cancer but when you have longer
telomeres you're probably doing better
the cause effect and what are what's the
importance in aging hasn't been causally
linked but but it's associated yeah near
i have to say there is so much data in
humans the mice model is not relevant
here when it comes to telomeres they are
so long they do not die of short
telomers but in humans there is
converging evidence as much evidence as
you can have in humans since we can't
manipulate telomeres directly that there
is a causal pathway so besides the
genetic disorders with the low
telomerase and early death we have
mendelian randomization studies of low
telomerase or telomer low telomerase
genes or short telomere genes predicting
common diseases of aging earlier so with
that as that's direct and causal in it
as much as we can get with humans but
but that but then uh let me ask you then
uh
if you're saying mice telomere telomeres
are long so they're not good for
human aging
how come mice are aging within three
years and humans are aging within 80
years right it really means that
telomeres
telomeres are not the major driving of
aging because aging happens so much more
faster in animals yeah
so in in the animal model it's when we
have these long-lived species that we
see that um we can more easily see that
it's that shortening of telomeres that
is contributing it's predicting and
maybe it's more marker than mechanism
but to say there's no mechanism in it
it's been so well mapped out
in in so many models and
you know in birds it's a it's a
very good predictor of
of their longevity and you can
manipulate telomeres in different ways
and shorten longevity um with
glucocorticoids
even laura i want to bring into the
conversation alyssa made reference to
cell senescence as
one of the parts of the pathway that
telomeres are connected with that's an
area in which your work focuses can give
a sense of what that is and its
relevance to aging sure well
cellular senescence is a response of an
individual cell to stress
and so we're all made up of over a
trillion cells and so these are you know
think of you have to think at the
cellular level right now so if a cell
detects that it's stressed for a variety
of reasons and it could be short
telomeres it could be dna damage
anywhere in the genome or mitochondrial
stress then it's going to activate a
signaling pathway
that will cause that cell
to have a stable arrest of its cell
cycle so what that means is it's not
going to replicate its genome
and it's not going to produce any more
daughter cells and that is a very very
potent tumor suppressor mechanism so it
prevents that damaged stress cell from
turning into a cancer so that's lovely
so we like senescence it's good for us
it's also very important in an acute
fashion for wound healing in other
physiological processes
but the problem is
as we get older i think that inevitable
decay leads to more and more stress and
then more and more senescent cells and
one of their key features is
they have a very robust secret home so
they're sending out signals to their
environment all of the time
and these signals are meant to
attract immune cells to get rid of these
stress damaged cells
and unfortunately our immune system
decays in function over as we age as
well so we we're making more senescent
cells we're not clearing them as as much
as we should and this leads to a state
of chronic inflammation that we believe
is is one of the hallmarks of aging that
puts you on a platform where you're set
up to be vulnerable to a number of
different diseases all of the diseases
of old age so starting to ask a very
basic question i think all of us have a
sense of what inflammation is at a macro
level
redness puffiness swollen
what does it mean at a cellular or even
a molecular level what does inflammation
mean at that scale
well it means your immune system is is
revved up a bit
and that you've got a lot of molecules
that are secreted from these immune
cells or the senescent cells and they're
just triggering um
kind of i think of it as
misinformation cross wiring of some of
the um
signals that your body would like to
receive to work in a healthy
coordinated fashion and so this is
particularly true with senescent cells i
think they're giving false signals to
the immune system
and just kind of screwing up the wiring
in the body and we saw this very clearly
when we started to study for instance
the role of senescent cells in causing
bad outcomes in coven 19.
the immune system in the elderly was
unable to mount a healthy immune
response because they're getting cross
signals from their their senescent cells
and it really screws everything up so
that misinformation is a nice segue to
you david i know that your focus has
been on
trying to find
what i guess i would call
the the in physics we call it the holy
grail trying to find the unified theory
the fundamental
guiding principles that govern the
particles and the laws and einstein look
for it and we're still on his trail
trying to find the unified theory of
physics you're kind of trying to find a
unified theory that would talk about all
of these processes of aging
in a manner that might allow us to have
a
cogent coherent organization perhaps
that would allow us to really find the
root cause of aging and i think that you
think that you found that root cause and
it has to do with information can you
tell us what your thinking is on that
yeah well so about
15 years ago we came together as a field
with these uh
nine hallmarks of aging and we it became
much less controversial to be in this
field unfortunately
uh so we all got along uh then i thought
i'd throw something out there that that
people could could attack and and the
idea is that
um
it started 20 years ago i was actually
more than that i was
26 years old working at mit
and i was part of a group that
discovered
that a set of longevity genes that could
extend lifespan in yeast cells
uh were working effectively and could
control
the response to diet and to temperature
uh and these genes were called sirtuins
well we ended up calling them sirtuins
and the sir part of that name stands for
silent information regulator and that
just means these genes controlled other
genes
in what we now regard as the epi genome
and so i've been working on that idea
ever since
trying to figure out if what we learned
in yeast cells the control of other
genes the epigenome
was also relevant to our own aging
process
and we've been trying to disprove that
hypothesis for for over two decades and
we haven't been able to disprove it so i
figured i may as well put it out there
as a possible valid theory and the idea
is that
there are really two types of
information in the body there's the
genome which is the genetic information
the the actg this is digital information
and then there's the other type of
information in the body which we
don't talk about as much mainly because
we didn't have the tools to read that
information until recently
and the epigenome consists of the
three-dimensional structure
of the dna loops
and uh so you could see that the the
loops of dna the double double helix
is wrapped around proteins these are
called histones and then those proteins
are wrapped together to form eventually
a structure that we call the chromosome
and at the very tips
are those telomeres
and the idea is that
it's not so much the loss of the genetic
material the dna
as we age that's causing aging which is
a very old theory going back more than
60 years now
my idea and and some others
uh is that it's the epigenetic
information that is lost over time in
other words if we use an analogy uh that
i like which is
a dvd player uh and for the very young
viewers uh and listeners these are
little uh discs that we used to put
movies on
uh that the digital information is the
is the code for the movie and the
epigenome is the the laser that reads
that information
in the same way that there are proteins
and structures shown
uh in this image here of the epigenome
being able to decide which genes are
turned on and off
and the way the cell actually does this
physically
is that the bundles of dna are silent
in part done uh mediated by these silent
information regulators that we
discovered control aging and then there
are loops of dna that open up and now
the dna can be read by the cell
and that has to be different in each
type of cell so a brain cell is going to
have a different set of loops and
bundles compared to a liver cell
compared to a skin cell because
all the dna is is the same in these
cells they have to be controlled
differently so in the same way that the
cell controls its genes a dvd player can
play different chapters of a movie and
will do so to make different stories and
what we proposed and have since
discovered is that during aging
this reader becomes disrupted and starts
to read the wrong genes in the genome
plays the wrong chapters in the wrong
order and you get a terrible story in
the case of the cell you get a terrible
uh functioning cell and we're proposing
that
many if not all of the causes of aging
or the hallmarks of aging
are related to changes in the epigenome
and you could think of aging now as
scratches on that dvd
that prevent that beautiful
chapter story of of the movie from
proceeding and that's exciting because
it means that the information
to be young is still in our bodies if
you could just polish the dvd or reset
the cell
to remember how to read the right genes
like they were young again you could
literally reverse aging and we have just
begun to do that in my lab and a few
others around the world so we're going
to get to some of the experiments
exciting experiments that you've been
doing but near when you i'm sure you're
familiar with david's theory does it
resonate with your insights on on aging
sure look there's a a really striking
example we could take a sperm of a 90
year old man and fertilize an egg of a
50 year old woman right
and and we can check we can actually
measure the age
but
when
the
the blastocyst when when these babies
start to develop when the cell starts to
divide they start at zero right so we
found a way to erase aging but
but i i want to say something
in order to understand what we just
heard we we mentioned the hallmarks of
aging how do you become a hallmark of
aging you have to show that it changes
with aging and if you fix it
you have effect on pre-clinical model
you know in animals you have effect on
their health span and lifespan
and so it's not necessarily the causes
of aging right it's just that that's
what we have
and the interesting thing is that you
fix one hallmark you affect the other
and that's why we have this liberty to
fight about the hierarchy right david
said it's epigenetics and and laura said
it's a it's uh senescence cells and and
the tillamoo you know and the telomeres
and you didn't ask me what's my my
hallmark
and and
i'm not saying there's no hierarchy
but uh but but but i'm saying the
complexity is because we affect each
other and we'll figure it out
and in my mind what david is saying
is for me the peter pan uh hypothesis i
think that the easiest thing that we'll
have in our field in the future maybe 50
years from now maybe sooner with david
or if david lasts
is we can take in a 20 year old
and erase his epigenetics and slow aging
significantly because i think the
easiest thing
is not to age i think to take an old
person and make it young again is
probably the hardest thing to do
although we've been doing that
in a way
so i i think the hierarchy will become
a
clear but
don't forget any whatever is your favor
you know they
when they ask me what's your favorite
hallmark i say if you have eight
daughters do i ask you who's your
favorite daughter
i don't want to be in this situation
they're all my favorite and by the way
the reason you don't want to commit is
some of them are going to be targeted
sooner than others right you don't want
to get the investors to invest in
something else when actually you can
have success right away so i'm i'm
trying just to be here the
uh the moderator the the moderator of of
those things so can you just quickly
tell us what are what are those
hallmarks i mean we've spoken about some
of them but david you mentioned
nine that were focused upon nearly just
mentioned number eight
is there some
master list
of of cellular
qualities that we will associate with
aging well yeah we draw it as a pie
chart and we give each slice the same
amount of space there are equal pies but
i don't think they're equal and it also
doesn't show that they're totally in
interconnected so for example
uh laura talks about senescent cells a
lot and this clearly is a is a problem
during aging and drives the process
the the end product of the dysregulation
of the epigenome the scratches on the
dvd we see is cellulosin essence
we also see that telomere shortening
disrupts the epigenome we see that the
epigenome changes disrupt nutrient
sensing and energy production in the
body which is what near studies so i'm
trying to unify us all and realize that
we're just holding the same elephant
from different ends so what are these
what are the what's this list well we
can debate how many there are but
there's roughly eight or nine
there's genomic instability and dna
mutations there's the loss of telomeres
the loss of uh
protein homeostasis which is recycling
of proteins we get old proteins gives us
alzheimer's for example macular
degeneration
deregulated nutrient sensing is is like
diabetes our bodies don't respond to
nutrients anymore uh we also have
mitochondrial dysfunction the energy
little power packs in the cell don't
work well
uh you can have senescent cells that
laura is talking about and stem cells
are important as well and then we throw
in a ninth one which would be epigenomic
dysregulation that i've just described
got it so alyssa we've been talking a
lot now about the internal
qualities of aging or markers of aging
you spend a lot of time thinking about
the external
effects of the environment or even a
state of mind on the kind of aging that
individual goes through i think you call
this the exosome if i'm pronouncing that
correctly it can tell us what that is
and and the kinds of things that your
research has revealed good question
the exposome is the sum of all of the
things that we are exposed to thank you
for closing
and so it's uh
some of it's measurable some of it's not
we tend to think of it as you know the
chemicals and the air pollution
and the
you know how safe our neighborhood is
that actually predicts you know health
and mortality in population-based data
and so a lot of the the common pathway
for these exosome factors is the stress
response the the gene body's generic
chronic stress response and that
includes elevated levels of inflammation
uh insulin resistance and cortisol and
so that generic stress response is aging
when it goes on and on so acutely it
helps us recover we need it it's healthy
in fact acute stressors are fabulous for
um kind of exercising the muscle of our
you know cellular resistance or cellular
stress response but the chronic stress
is wearing to these cellular systems
and uh
um i think the you know the intrinsic
aging that we're talking about and that
these three amazing colleagues are
working on in a mechanistic way
so important to understand it's so
important to invest more money in
studying these mechanisms and we will
eventually have some
uh some you know
pills that will help us we're all
waiting we're getting closer
but the
that the big factors that shape our
aging
are
really
are the biggest factors kind of
were you born to a wealthy family or
were you born in poverty and these
social economic factors
um are the biggest drivers of early
disease and aging so there's there's
these kind of levels of
predictors we call that the social
determinants of health
and then there's what we can control our
individual lifestyle and behavior and of
course our mindset our
levels of well-being and stress all of
these are associated with
our health
and
the
what i'm so excited about interested in
is studying the hallmarks of aging
and how
these external factors are social
environment or relationships uh
factors related to climate change and of
course stress how these
speed up the drivers of aging the
biological drivers of aiding so we talk
about chronic stress are there some
concrete examples that you've studied
which show that
kind of ongoing stress has this impact
on on aging yes so as as an example one
of the typical ways we study stress is
caregivers
and so we they're under chronic stress
they're not able to take care of
themselves it's usually at least 10
years that someone is caring for a
family member with dementia or if it's a
parent it's it could be lifelong caring
for a child with a developmental
disorder etc so those in those models we
find telomere shortening elevated levels
of systemic inflammation
and we also find uh accelerated
epigenetic
patterns that indicate aging epigenetic
clocks
the other factor that's associated with
these
um
aspects of cellular aging is traumatic
early stress we also know that early
both prenatally and in childhood
severe stress is associated with a long
shadow of accelerated aging these these
same markers poor mitochondria function
epigenetic aging
telomere shortening and inflammation and
there's also a study you did if i'm not
mistaken on on the relationship between
racism
and aging give us a sense of what you
found there so there's been a
now more than a handful of studies in
population-based studies like on the
health and retirement study by various
groups
especially david shea
at tulane and these studies consistently
find
that
ex greater experiences of discrimination
predict
not just shorter telomeres but shorter
um
greater rate of telomere shortening over
time over 10 years in the in the last
study that came out in 2020 so we do
think that this is one form of systemic
stress we know that there are um
race differences in telomere length that
we're still trying to figure out but
we're not going to be able to measure
systemic racism very well we just
uh know that when we measure experiences
of discrimination it's related to
telomere shortness in a dose response
fashion
so if we turn now to
how we can can i say something just just
an example i have an
uncle who's in my study he's 99 years
old with launch telomeres now
when he was 16
the nazis killed his parents took him
and he says i had the tour of five
concentration camps he said the nazis
gave me the great tour not enough food
but they paid for everything
and he survived that he went to medical
school in prague and in 1968 in the the
spring of prague he he was an activist
so he had to escape
from the russians he escaped eventually
got to quebec and the separatists have
blown the house next to him and then he
went to houston and
you know it's going on and on he built
now his house third time after hurricane
so it's an example for somebody who had
periods of stress
throughout his life and and you just
think that it upgraded his ability
to deal with stress and i'm kind of
hoping somewhat for the next hurricane
to keep him alive you know but
but i think that that demonstrates a
little bit the levels of stress and what
they do well no doubt one state of mind
and how one deals with stress elicit
presumably is a vital part of its impact
on you physiologically i presume it's a
beautiful example
near yep so laura if we turn now to
possible ways that we can start to deal
with aging i know that you've developed
drugs that deal with some of the cell
senescence that we were talking about
earlier what's the state of play on on
that kind of uh pharmacological response
to to aging yeah so it's a really
exciting time in the field um
i think of senescent cells maybe not as
a pillar or hallmark of aging but the
transducer of aging so we have very
strong genetic evidence
that if you get rid of senescent cells
you will have less age-related diseases
and what's really exciting to me is at
least in in mouse models
um if you get rid of senescence cells
through these genetic tricks what you do
is you extend median lifespan but not
necessarily maximum lifespan so what i
interpret that to mean is you've you've
blunted all cause mortality in this
population and that's exciting you
really then
senescent cells are are a foundation of
all of these age-related diseases that
we fear
so if you could do that with genetics of
course we were thinking can we do this
with drugs and so we started developing
um what we call cenotherapeutics and
they come in two flavors
one are a class of drugs that
specifically kill these senescent cells
so the the main goal there is to just
get rid of the source of this chronic
inflammation that happens with aging
and the others are cenomorphics so they
alter the senescent cell phenotype
and that
dampens
the inflammation so you can approach it
two different ways and
we've been using bioinformatic
approaches to try and define senescent
cells and sort of in a traditional
pharmaceutical approach look for
molecular targets that would make a
senescent cell very vulnerable to cell
death
and then we've also just been doing
screening so we can take
in in the laboratory plates of senescent
cells and just apply drugs that exist
natural products that exist and look for
things that will selectively kill
senescent cells
and it's just been tremendously exciting
because the first center therapeutics
were identified in 2015
and we're already deep into
numerous clinical trials so the hope is
we will know in a very short period of
time if this approach
to modify aging is really going to work
and so you mentioned before that they're
kind of good senescent cells and bad
ones
is there a way that these drugs can tell
the difference between the two and just
target the bad ones that's a great
question so um
i think what we're struggling with right
now in the field is a good definition of
a senescent cell and if i if it were my
way
you know to to organize all of this we
would probably call healthy senescent
cells and
uh pathologic senescence cells something
different so that we we could even
linguistically discriminate but i can
promise you at this point drugs cannot
and so we have to think very carefully
about how to apply
senalytics in particular to get the
benefits without adverse outcomes i mean
when do they go bad is there is there a
well-defined process
that that there's a transitioning or
some just good and some just bad from
the get-go well i think they what we
think of is the healthy senescence cells
are are transient which makes no sense
when we're talking about a stable or
irreversible cell cycle arrest and
and and so it's it's also plays into the
immune system if if uh
an acute situation like wound healing
requires senescent cells you can drive
the immune system in close that wound
very expeditiously but then clear away
those senescent cells so i think
short-lived
versus chronic that hang around your
body can't get rid of them and they're
just kind of festering like a rotten
apple
corrupting the bushel but a drug is not
going to be sophisticated enough to tell
the difference yet until we can define
senescent cells with much greater
clarity
right so david with your perspective the
unified approach to aging
what is your prescription for how we
might address it
well first of all we should all know
that we can do a lot in our current
lives in the way we live
we should talk a little bit maybe later
about
the kind of things that we do ourselves
to try and uh slow down the aging
process
in terms of pharmaceutical development
laura's
really one of the leaders in
finding molecules that can address
one of the major hallmarks of aging
one of the things that i find
surprises people is to learn how many
clinical trials are ongoing and how many
positive results we've had from this
field we have positive results in humans
for
analytics we have positive results
already for
these nad boosting molecules in the
field that we work on and telomere
extension there's some good
uh early results there and of course
nearest field which is nutrient sensing
and type 2 diabetes we have a drug
called metformin which i think is the
leading candidate for a safe longevity
drug that's already prescribed by
doctors and so what i would say is um
well i've actually you know written a
book on this to say what i think could
be done in people's lives both lifestyle
and supplements and
one day medicines
um and it's it's a long list but the way
to think of it is you want to put your
body in a state of perceived adversity
because the body has its own repair
systems that become lazy if you sit
around and you're always fed and you're
always the right temperature and we can
either do those uncomfortable things and
get our bodies to wake up so do some
exercise eat less often eat foods that
themselves have been stressed we can
also take molecules such as the drug
metformin that near is an expert in or a
synalytic drug or a telomere extender
that actually mimic this adversity
which in combination with a healthy
lifestyle
i think will have remarkably strong
benefits on longevity
if not
delaying these diseases that uh come way
too early in my opinion so concretely
how when you talk about stress there i
mean alyssa was talking about how you've
got you know acute and chronic stress
perhaps from a psychological perspective
and the cute is better than the chronic
in terms of how we respond are you
basically saying the same thing at a
more physiological level that we need to
strain ourselves in a way that that's
aligned with the acute stress that we
were talking about before yeah well
let's separate psychological stress from
biological stress when i say stress and
adversity i mean
uh the body reacting to what it
perceives as
uh the chance that it could die next
week from
from you know getting eaten by a
saber-toothed tiger or starving for a
lack of food but you don't want to go
there you don't want to have to starve
or be chased down
by a predator to actually get this
longevity so we mimic it so
instead of prescribing things because
i'm i'm just a phd and we don't know the
full answer of course i like to talk
about what i do and my and sometimes
what my father does and daily
um
which i'm happy to do yeah please right
now yeah i'd love to hear it um all
right well
so um
there are three main staples um and i've
actually added a fourth based on laura's
work
uh i still take a gram of resveratrol
every morning with a bit of yogurt to
dissolve it because it's
it doesn't dissolve in water and that
activates the sirtuin
enzyme we've many others have shown now
seems to be very safe in humans so the
risk is low and remind us that your two
in enzyme is the one that helps repair
the epigenome is that the uh
in part so yeah the sort of there are
seven of them in the body and they do
various activities they
boost mitochondria they seem to slow
senescence they even protect the
telomere ends of the chromosomes but one
of their main functions in fact the the
reason they were first linked to aging
was their critical role in slowing down
aging of the epigenome these scratches
on the dvd
and so by taking resveratrol the hope
has been that i will be resistant to a
bad diet which we've shown in animals
but also it will slow down the ticking
of the aging clock and i didn't know if
that was going to happen 13 14 years ago
when i started
but it certainly hasn't done me any harm
so far but again the supplements are
unproven so i'm not advocating for this
i'm just telling you what i've chosen to
do
the next thing is an nad booster which
is nad is a molecule that also is fuel
for these protective sort of enzymes in
the body and then the third component
actually is what near is that a pill is
that a pill that that i mean how do you
boost that nad um so resveratrol is a
powder that i just keep around i nmn is
a capsule
i take a gram of that every day in the
morning and then at night i take a gram
of metformin which is the type 2
diabetes drug now
that might strike people as strange that
i don't yet have type 2 diabetes i might
eventually get there but i'm taking it
as a preventative not just of type 2
diabetes but
based on the evidence it's probably
going to slow down the development of
cancer heart disease and even
alzheimer's based on
retrospective studies of tens of
thousands of people and those are the
three main ones the fourth one that i've
added that uh that laura doesn't even
know is i'm taking
uh a molecule that she and her team has
shown extends life span in mice
and that's physin and so i do take that
uh regularly as well in the hopes that
it will do what laura says is good uh
kill off and slow down the formation of
senescent cells but also what's not
widely knows that we discovered physique
and the same molecule
activates these sortings as well we
showed that back in 2003. so you get a
double whammy for zetan so i sometimes
throw that in the yogurt as well
but can we get all those pills at like
gnc is this all widely publicly
available are you going to like the
reserves over there in the harvard lab
and just picking off the shelf oh boy
brian you're going to get me in trouble
no i don't raid the lab at harvard
that's for sure
um i'm very careful to
uh go for supplies of
these molecules that are trusted brands
and that they're 100 or near 100 pure
uh i think it's worth mentioning that
the supplement world is filled with
a number of products that are
untrustworthy some of them don't even
have the product in them unfortunately
it's not well regulated um so i'm very
careful to do that and also i think if
somebody wants to look at supplements
they should look for what's called gmp
good manufacturing practices or
procedures
and this helps guarantee that the people
making the product actually
uh do take extra care right but it's
hard i admit
um but i also want to say that i'm not
just popping pills i do
what i what i also believe is good for
health which is i eat well so it's more
like a mediterranean diet it's more
vegan these days i avoid sugar
and i eat uh one and a half times a day
which i also believe is going to help my
ultimate longevity but i'm not so
worried about my own death i'm not
scared of death i i do like
experimenting and and it's kind of a
competition to see who can be the
healthiest and longest lived at this
point
yeah so laura how does it make you feel
when david says that he's taken a a drug
that you were involved with that you
didn't even know that he was taking is
that again something that
um is out there in the world and and is
something that you would suggest people
to take or does it surprise you to hear
that it does not surprise me at all
because david is very adventurous
so
and i'm flattered and i have to say back
at you david because i tried taking nad
precursors because i believe in your
work so strongly but i am a a test case
an example i got horribly sick off of
commercial products because you really
and this is from reputable companies as
well so you do have to be extremely
careful the other thing i would caution
is the doses that david is talking about
has nothing to do with what's on the
back of a bottle so there's not really
good guidance out there for the average
consumer so i would urge a lot of
caution let the studies happen
facetime is being tested at a number of
clinical trials right now we do know
that it clears senescent cells so just
wait for those those scientific studies
to
come out because it you won't have to
wait too long
so near metformin was described as one
of the drugs that at least david and
perhaps others are taking the drug that
you've been deeply involved with tell us
about that and again is it something
where you feel that there's evidence
supporting the idea that this is a
longevity aiding a
drug sure so it's interesting i came as
a fellow to yale in 1970 in 1987
and my project was to find the mechanism
of action of metformin which was a drug
that was used in europe but but people
said it should be used in the united
states too
and so i'm on the first paper that
described this mechanism of action of
metformin that's related to diabetes but
i knew then
that diabetes was kind of a side effect
of metformin because metformin was used
to prevent flu and malaria and to treat
inflammatory disease when it was
discovered that it also lowers glucose
in diabetics okay but but i didn't think
much about it until much later when it
started to be clear
that there's a whole geros science we
call it not anti-aging we call it
geroscience part of metformin actually
papers like david who showed that the
clinical dose of metformin extends
lifespan in animal and the fact that it
increased health spin even much more
profoundly and and significantly
and then the realization that metformin
hits all the hallmark of aging and by
the way
does it affect all the hallmarks of
aging
part of this hallmark story is that
if you have a drug that actually takes
an old cell or an old organ or an old
body and make younger then you repair
lots of things so you see the epigenetic
improves and you see so it looks like it
it it corrects everything
but
the reason i took metformin is not
because of my own research but actually
is part of our leadership that
metformin seemed to be the right way the
right tool i'm calling it a tool
to go to the fda and say hey look you
have a drug that we want to repurpose to
target aging so let's talk about it
let's do the study that will show
that when we give metformin
we're targeting aging which means
we're going to target not one or two or
three diseases but all those diseases
and mortality
and and then you know we can call it
aging we don't have to call it aging but
at least we have a template and an
outcomes that will show that it's
happening now the preliminary data and
david you said association studies
most of the studies in metformin that we
have are clinical studies okay
clinical study is that they took
patients and some of them got that and
some of them get placebo or another
effect so metformin prevents diabetes
compared to placebo metformin it
prevents cardiovascular disease compared
to other
to other drugs metformin prevents the
deterioration in mild cognitive
impairment
the cancer
is more of association but there are 250
association studies that all show that
no matter what cancer actually maybe not
in prostate but all other cancers if you
give metformin you get 30 percent less
less of those cancers and there's a
really good study on mortality that
showed that people who take metformin 78
000 people
in the study there were almost 200 000
but the 78 000 people on metformin
uh that have diabetes
had less mortality than people without
diabetes and their their diabetes they
were more obese they were more sick in
the beginning and they still had better
less mortality so if you take all of it
together you see that this is the
perfect tool and remember it might we
might have better drugs but we don't
want to kill anyone on the way to
succeed to success
we want to do the right study at the
right time with the right population and
show that we're moving no matter what
disease you're going to get you'll get
it later or not at all in a five-year
window so alyssa when you hear about all
these drugs
that you know various of your colleagues
have been working on and even taking
themselves how do you think about them
in reference to your work which shows
that there's such an impact of of the
external world i mean if you had the
greatest pill in the world but the
external world doesn't change do you
think you're going to have the effects
that these drugs are seeking i have been
very skeptical because aging is so
complex with so many redundant
mechanisms i never thought we'd get here
i also know that
our behaviors are so strong they can
override the drug effects so for example
a diabetic taking metformin it's going
to protect them
to the um only to a certain extent if
they are chronically eating over
processed food and high sugar and it's
not going to keep them the uh insulin
sensitive so you know what we can do can
ruin the drug effect and override it and
um these are pretty strong effects that
we're talking about the chronic stress
being sedentary junk food that but um
i have i think i've drunk the kool-aid
this research is really really exciting
now i pretty much
uh take what david takes partly based on
your research and the research we've
talked about here
and you know there's always risk right
we don't have the careful dose response
studies i'm not gonna wait five years
i'm gonna you know we're always kind of
doing what we think is safe um ahead of
the
you know the longitudinal studies that
just take too long
so so david there are studies obviously
that need to be done of of these drugs
their effects on humans you've
definitely done some powerful work
already with mice
that have shown the capacity to reverse
certain kind of cellular damage and so
forth you have a sense of what that is
well there's been a lot done over the
last 20 years not just by my lab but but
by dozens of others and it may be a
surprise to not to learn that there are
oh probably close to 70 companies now
working on aging to develop molecules to
slow down and treat
the process and and diseases that result
from that by mostly by turning on the
cell
the cell's natural defenses against
aging
and so what's come out of out of my lab
are a couple of main areas i talked
about the red wine molecule called
resveratrol there are molecules that
that act like that
on humans and they had positive results
in a disease called psoriasis skin
inflammation we also have nad boosters
which also activate this these same
enzymes that protect the body and we
have been do we've been doing clinical
trials for the last two and a half years
no adverse effects
uh early results look promising and then
a third area that we haven't yet gone
into humans yet but i think is
even more exciting and controversial is
actual reprogramming the epigenome to
literally reverse the age of parts of
the body and perhaps one day the entire
body now that's still in mice actually
we're now in non-human primates to test
the safety
but ultimately what i hope in the next
two years is we will treat our first
patient and what we're focusing on is
not reversing the whole body aging that
would be too much to to try first up but
what we'd like to do is reverse
blindness so in mice we publish that we
can reverse the age of an old eye and
cure blindness and that's what we're
going to focus on in humans if we can do
it and if you try to immediately apply
that technique to the whole body of the
mass have you tried to do that
is there something that goes wrong
no nothing goes wrong actually it goes
very right we know that we can reverse
the age not just of the optic nerve and
make it regrow
and get back the age of the eye so that
it functions normally again we've also
tested it
on well first of all different parts of
the eye we can do different parts of the
retina we've now done skin
we've
been able to control aging very
carefully and precisely in the brain of
a mouse we can drive it in a forwards
direction make it get old
get dementia
get alzheimer's or form of alzheimer's
and then the cool part is we can now
reverse the age of the brain we infect
the brain with three embryonic genes
turn them on the brain of the mouse gets
young again and it gets its abilities to
learn again uh it actually
we think it might even get lost memories
back again
so we're there's nothing that i can see
yet that makes me concerned i mean one
possibility is that it could make the
cells too young and a very very young
cell is a tumor we don't want that but i
think we've been very lucky actually to
discover that there's a combination of
just three genes that we we put in the
cells that seem to be really quite safe
and if we turn those genes on for over a
year in a mouse and just blast it
through the whole mouse we don't get any
evidence of tumors in fact we see fewer
tumors now the question is do they live
longer and we're of course doing that
right now uh we actually unfortunately
had to kill our mice
uh because the reviewers of our paper
that we published a year ago
insisted that we look at their organs uh
so we needed to do that so we're
repeating that experiment with in fact
better delivery systems for the gene
therapy so that we can get more even
distribution of these embryonic genes
and we'll see
but it's super exciting times to be able
to potentially reset the body of an
animal not just once but many times
and then you know all bets are off if it
even works slightly in humans david if
you allow your your nad boosted fertile
imagination to run wild and imagine that
things go as best as they possibly can
in say the next 50 years
what would it be like if this kind of
protocol were to be applied to humans
would you would you go every so often to
get sort of a treatment and you'd leave
the spa feeling like 15 years younger
kind of thing what what would it be like
yeah i'm
enthusiastic like alyssa just expressed
that where we are now i didn't believe
we could get to in my lifetime and just
the last few years with works work on
telomeres analytics and metformin it
makes my head spin how quickly this is
moving so it's very hard to see 50 years
into the future
let alone five
but i could imagine a future we have the
technology now at least in mice and
there's no reason why it shouldn't work
in humans to reset the age of the body
to extend telomeres to delete the
senescent cells or even cure them using
our technology
and reset the age of the body not just
by one year but by 10 years or more
and interestingly if you think about
if you just go back one year every
birthday
you don't die now we're not there yet
but i could see in 50 years that would
be commonplace for people to reset their
age every decade and then just age out
again and get another treatment by a
doctor i mean how long do you imagine
this could could go on this cycle
indefinitely probably not indefinitely
there are things that happen to the
genome we do get mutations and that's
information that may be irretrievable
but
you know there is no limit to biological
age in humans there are plenty of
species that live for thousands of years
and there are
very closely related mammals uh the
whales that live
200 years so you know when somebody says
oh we've reached our maximum you know
i'm happy to debate that i think that
that's wrong and that we can learn from
these other species how they manage to
have fewer senescent cells
fewer telomere losses and a very stable
epigenome and when we apply that
knowledge i don't see why we can't have
people 50 years from now who are
reaching
you know dare i say at 150 because think
about this the longer you live the
better this technology gets and uh so
the idea now is we need to stay alive as
this technology comes online and live
longer and the longer we live the longer
we will live so so we could be that like
transition generation where
we just missed it by uh by a couple
years or something of that sort it could
be we could be the last generation that
lives a normal pathetic human lifespan
and future generations will take pity on
us well but that is a transition i just
want to go on to maybe some of the
philosophical or ethical issues here is
everybody on board that we should be
doing this i mean we're all speaking as
if the goal of living longer is is the
right goal and and pursuing it is the
right thing i think we'd all agree that
being healthier for longer i think
that's pretty incontrovertible right we
want to do that that's not a
controversial statement but you know you
could say that natural selection right
it it it wanted us to survive to the age
of reproduction and after that doesn't
care so much about us from that
perspective should we be messing with
that natural rhythm
look life expectancy for tens thousands
of years was like between 25 and 35.
and we made this deal with the devil and
we said we're unhappy you know because
there were always old people who are
doing well right
and and so the devil said fine i'll give
you water i'll give you sewers i'll give
you immunization i'll give you surgery
and what did we get
we got a bunch of terrible age-related
diseases right
so
do we need to accept that
um i'm more worried
not not that people will understand that
health span is important i think that
maybe we're making another deal with the
devil and in 50 years there'll be new
diseases okay but when we'll get there
we'll we'll know about it but i i don't
see if we agree
that aging drives diseases and we want
to prevent it
i don't see why the individual will care
so much and let me give you the example
that really drives me
our centenarians it's not only that they
live long okay
they live healthier they get diseases 30
years after a current cohort get
diseases
and and even at age 100 30 percent of
our centenarians don't have any disease
okay
and this is not really the important
thing that they live longer and and
their health spin was increased but they
have what's called the contraction of
morbidity we're sick five eight years at
the end of our life and they are sick
for between
not at all to few weeks or months
this contraction of morbidity also
has been shown by the the impact of that
has been shown by the cdc who shows
that the medical cost in the last two
years of life of somebody who dies after
the age of 100 is third of those who die
when they're 70. and our centenarians
when they were 70 they didn't even go to
the doctor
and this has been translated to a
longevity dividend so it's not only
it's not only
the health spend that is good okay it's
it's how much we're freeing
the economy
and in fact david david you should talk
about the andrew scott
paper because when when the elderly are
healthy
it's not only the medical expense they
travel they shop the value that they
contribute is increasing so there is a
personal medical reason
for you
to be healthy
and die
very shortly or not without any disease
and there's a motivation for our economy
to free
huge amount of of money that we spend on
treating diseases that should have been
prevented to begin with laura you have a
similar view or different i agree
completely with near i think it's our
moral obligation to tackle this it's
it's the greatest biomedical problem
that we kind of created by having all of
these advanced researches that took away
early life diseases and and we have to
tackle this now we don't have
a hospital system that can accommodate
so many elderly with multiple diseases
of old age we don't have the doctors we
don't have the caregivers
um and but i'm also a little skeptical
about how well it's ultimately going to
work because of this huge elephant in
the room that alissa talks about the
environment we have to clean up
everything if we're really going to get
the most benefit from this and listen
what's your overall view is this uh the
the right goal that that we should
pursue vigilantly i have a question from
my colleagues instead of answering and i
like what you said um laura and nier
and i
love uh
your um
your vision david
but really i think it's a question for
david if we live to 150 years
how do you see
us
doing what we you know we kind of call
carbon offsets you know how do we we
have seven billion people we have
overpopulation
uh we have
uh
we have
i'm not going to say an unpredictable
future we have a future of worsening and
worsening
of the climate crisis we have an
unstable climate we will have famines we
have we're going to have problems with
breadbaskets and immigration
and uh and so i'm just curious you know
how does this fit in if we're if we're
living longer if we're really talking
about population health not just elite
you know
people of extreme wealth being able to
live long but if we're really able to
extend life how do we
balance that with the earth's health
well it it clearly goes along with this
and the good news is that
when people are living longer
and healthier as near said
are there a huge savings so i
co-published with andrew scott
a london economist that the value just
to the economy in the us
of using let's say metformin to give
people an extra year of healthy life one
year
the value to the economy in the long run
is 86 trillion dollars with a t
and if you live another 10 years it's
365 trillion dollars this is savings
this is an expenditure right so
it's the best way to take money out of
waste out of the sick care system rather
than the health care system as we call
it and put it into other things that we
need to do
but why not you can do it for rentals
there's no question that compressing
morbidity what near laid out is is a
necessary goal we're you know we're so
sick and we spend and we have a bankrupt
health care system as well as a burnt
out health care system
so the the compression morbidity yes
i mean this is why these drugs are just
so important but it's the living the
extra 50 years
even if we're healthy this is an extra
burden on the earth yeah well i think
it's it's not a good thing to say uh we
want people to die to save money you
know
in 1840 people were complaining there
were too many people what are we gonna
do with all this horse manure uh too
many sick people and we we engineered
our way out of it london's now a great
place to live and there's at least three
times as many people in the city
science can fix things that's why we're
here that's why we're talking today and
there are solutions to this and i don't
think the answer is okay let's just make
sure we don't let people live longer
otherwise we should stop doing medical
research right now
great point and i would love to hear
from our colleagues about this you know
science the ability to do this
um
and wisdom the wisdom of doing this so
can i can i make a a
another point let me ask you let me ask
you and i'm doing a provocation now okay
um
so
we need it's not about elderly only you
know people who survive cancer and
chemotherapy which are aging by the way
they get age-related disease very soon
after kids are getting heart disease at
35. we need to help them people with hiv
get diseases ten years ahead okay
people who are disabled let's talk about
poor people okay poor people
live depending everywhere in the world
depending the extent but in the united
states 15 years less than
people with middle income okay
so so let's talk about it uh for a
second because
uh you're saying that
the best thing to do with poor people is
first of all they're not eating well
right they're eating too many calories
that are not appropriate for them
they don't do fish they don't know
vegetables and fruits because they're
expensive and even if they were not
expensive they don't like them
those people also do not exercise
because the gym
is lots of money and it's not available
and because peloton they cannot afford
or or tread meals
so
i think one of the options
is to give them at forming okay which by
the way have been working better in poor
people than in in rich people in in in
studies that we're looking at that now
for every dollar of metformin
it's estimated that we need to spend
hundred thousand dollars in order to
improve their diet and exercise which by
the way i'm totally in favor it's just a
huge
risk so don't you think that in a
certain way
uh
we'll have to deal with diet we'll have
to deal with exercise but wouldn't it'll
be good to have drugs that will have the
people who cannot get there
near if you're asking me absolutely what
i'm asking about is
the hundred to 150 years i'm asking is
that wise
so so my my answer to that look that's
why and david knows that i'm i'm trying
to answer these questions i'm trying to
say look
maximal lifespan of human species today
is about 115 years we can argue about it
somebody lived to be 122.
and but we die before the age of 80. so
there are 35 years that we can realize
and even that will take time to realize
but that doesn't mean
a that we cannot break it
and b that we shouldn't try to work on
it right now
but but i think i i but i think but that
that kind of answers it's a different i
think it's a different scientific
goal it's a little
a different scientific technology
and let's do it in stages let's start
with being healthy within our capacity
and in the meantime figuring maybe to do
it so
it's not a burden at all so in this
final minutes i just want to shift
somewhat more philosophical if you're
willing to go with me they're uh you
know the the great psychologist otto
ronk and then the cultural
anthropologist ernest becker
they both emphasize as well as many
other thinkers and writers how human
mortality
plays a vital role in the lives that we
lead the decisions we make the
motivations for our various behaviors
how we find meaning in our lives is
often reflected on the fact that we all
know that we're going to die
now if we were able to push off
mortality perhaps in the way that david
suggests to 150 or maybe you just keep
going back and get those treatments and
maybe it goes on even longer maybe to a
thousand years
do you think that we as a species are
going to find it more difficult
to find meaning and purpose within that
context or do we just ultimately
acclimate to the new lifespan and that
will be the norm when we just go forward
from there any thoughts on that laura i
think actually it would have a very
positive impact on our view of of
meaning i mean if you take the life
cycle of a scientist we barely get good
before we're
incapacitated as old scientists
so you know we spend so much effort
during our scientific lives training the
next generation because we know we're
not going to finish the story so at
least as a scientist i i can't imagine
as a dancer to be able to dance longer i
mean it would give so much meaning to to
just extend
quality life
david you're viewing that
uh yeah i do i don't think most of us
think about mortality each day
you know our our experiences what
happened last month what's gonna happen
in two months from now
and anything beyond that's not really in
our thought very much and you know
albeit for me to to disagree with
philosophers um and anthropologists but
uh in my my view having been a human 52
years
i don't get up every morning worried i'm
going to die i get up every morning
because it's a thrill to be alive and
i'm just excited about what i'm doing
that day and as long as i'm healthy and
i have
friends and family around i don't see
why that would want
need to end necessarily why
the fear of it ending makes me happier
and more driven i don't see that at all
no other people may be driven by a fear
of death but i think most of us are just
happy to have a good day and hang out
and do something that we find purposeful
and if that's being done in healthy way
at age 100 120 and i'm sure near can
talk about this with people he works
with that
their fear of death i don't think is a
major driver of our our happiness
and uh and what we do each day so near
what do you find i mean the super ages
that we began with
do they have an attitude that somehow is
different from the attitude of others do
they find meaning in longevity do you
think that's where things will
ultimately turn out to be well first i
want to make clear that i'm not
immortalist in fact
if if it's true that this world is go
this planet is going to survive for 12
billion years i have to tell you i'm i'm
tired for some things again i mean how
many i don't know
trump's we'll see how many disasters
we'll see
so look with the centenarians who some
of them
are
a lot of them are very active they're
painters they're working uh you know i
have a centenarians who's going to the
office he has a hedge fund 720 million
dollars goes every every day to to the
office and say if he'll be fired he'll
buy the company to work
when you have health spam
okay you don't want to stop you don't
want to stop working you don't want to
go to the theater what what's making
aging
terrible
is the diseases
it's not the chronological age so i i i
think it's something that we have to try
to provide so alyssa i know that you
have some qualms about the 100 to 150
range whether we should even target
human lifespan to lie within that
if it turns out that you know you guys
any of you on this discussion here
figure out how to achieve that
will you opt in
when the time comes
that that is it's always um a good
question to do that type of predicting
i love this discussion about purpose i
don't think we would lose purpose i
think it's like
my colleagues have said that you know
at least from our perspective we're all
privileged if the purpose in life is
partly to
to leave the world a better place to
reduce suffering we
what an exciting time this is we love
our work you know this is
um
this is
you're getting up every day excited
about what we can do what we can learn
but i want to bring in another view
about purpose there's another
big
trend
that is here that we we really shouldn't
ignore and that is
well i agree with near that well-being
and vitality is is really about health
and we will have no problem being
productive members if we have health
span
i also think mental health is
an equally
important part of the picture
and
here's what's happening we have a mental
health crisis we already did before
covet we have
126 million new cases of anxiety and
depression over the past year but here's
what i'm most concerned about a
worldwide survey
of youth in 10 countries
showed that 77 feel the future is
frightening
and why shouldn't they we really are
going to be facing so many more climate
disasters and and problems that is
predict that is not just a prediction
it's models for that
uh we don't know exactly for how long
but it will be our whole lifetime
here's what's worse 56 percent of youth
globally feel the humanity is doomed
so
depression annihilation lack of meaning
not wanting to have kids all of this is
here now
and part of our future so
i for me personally i'm so excited about
what's coming in pharmaceuticals to
increase health span but i am less
concerned about longevity over a hundred
i feel there are um i'm turning my
efforts more toward
uh toward looking at what we can do in
my area which is understanding
behavioral science of health and mental
health toward
climate
to climate mitigation issues and that is
a more immediate and big impact on our
mental health and our our physical
health so i just want to keep that in
the picture here when we think about
living to 150 yeah no it's absolutely
vital i just want to say something that
david david started
and i want to double down on that
that
look
the covet right infectious disease
showed that we have to
not only rejuvenate right the immune
system but the whole body so it's
resilient against severe diseases right
so we need to do aging for those
disasters that are coming
it's the same for climate change you
know we need better body when we age if
we're going to live in temperature of 90
degrees so i don't think those things
are mutually exclusive i think it's part
of it well it's been a fascinating
discussion
one final question before we uh wrap up
if you're willing i'd love for each of
you to just give
a guess a prognostication of where you
think again subject to all of the
caveats we've been talking about in the
best of all worlds if the science goes
spectacularly if we cure all the issues
with the drugs if we are able to deal
with climate change if we don't blow
ourselves up human lifespan in say 500
years near just give us a number where
do you where do you think it's going to
be um
500 years i i well
for sure by then we would break
we would break the this 115 record look
if we're going to space and if there are
aliens by the way that will come here
they've solved aging right because
they're coming farther than mars i mean
if we're going to mars without solving
aging we'll never get there healthy and
we'll never make it back
okay so if they're aliens that many
people believe they solve aging before
they'll come here so i i think that's if
that's 500 years that's what i'll say
i'll say we sold aging we're not going
to age dramatically by then so one thing
i'll just give on that if the aliens
have solved the problem of traveling
near the speed of light then because of
special relativistic time dilation they
may not have cracked the actual
physiological problem of aging but but
maybe you're right if they're doing it
at slow speeds then you're definitely
correct alyssa any physicist the
physicist
authoritatively i couldn't help it uh
alyssa thoughts on on where you think
the human lifespan will be in in say 500
years i think that if we are still alive
we will have had
major
um massive
transitional shifts in our culture
and
we can't do this the way we're living
now
which is
you know in a
a
competitive world with guns i mean gun
sales have never been as high this year
in the states at least i mean it's just
we're going to need to build our
resilience our hormetic stress responses
and our compassion for each other and
not be so insular and tribal and then
we'll have a chance of actually building
using our resources in a better way so
for me i'm you know i really uh
have my eye on
purpose and life quality of life and
health span and i'm i'm less obsessed
with the years but i leave that you know
to my brilliant colleagues here laura
any any thoughts on a number that we can
imagine the human lifestyle being in say
500 years
i would defer to david and say
if it was a hundred and fifty that would
be lovely
um but i think that's only gonna be
what's possible i think the average
lifespan is probably not going to change
dramatically because of all of these
other circumstances that impinge upon it
and so what i like to think of in terms
of a scientific success is if we can get
everybody
to 85 or
100 healthy that's going to be a huge
win
david final words where you think things
are going to be it's pretty easy to
extend lifespan of yourself it's been
shown that if you just do what we know
is good eat right don't over drink don't
overeat exercise sleep well
have friends uh you can live another 14
years over if you didn't do those things
smoking also is is a problem so if you
smoke please try to quit so that you can
get 14 years pretty pretty easily
if you add those technology we talked
about today and ones we can imagine
resetting the body multiple times and i
don't see why it wouldn't be possible in
500 years for
someone who's just had their
150th birthday to be having a midlife
crisis
um
i think eventually the sky's the limit i
think aliens would have already solved
this and they'd come to our planet and
they'd say look at these pathetic humans
they're still debating whether this is
even worth doing how sad is that
that means they're not yet
qualified to be in the club of uh
advanced civilizations until they've
figured that out and at least realize
that that's a problem they need to solve
and the fact that it's natural and it's
not yet solvable has nothing to do with
whether we should work on it in fact it
makes it more important because a
hundred thousand people die every day in
horrible ways because of aging so i
think that uh in the in the future sky's
the limit we already know species can
live for many hundreds of years
mammals such as whales so i i look
forward to that kind of a world but i
also agree with alyssa that we can't
just make people healthier and live
longer we have to make a planet livable
otherwise it's not worth it absolutely
so with that i just hope that all of you
will agree that if you are successful
that you will rejoin me
in the year 23 22 so we can have another
conversation on human longevity human
health ban and and hopefully the issue
of the climate will be long in the rear
view mirror we will long have resolved
that so thank you so much for i'll be
the oldest i'll be the oldest
it won't matter at that point but yes
thank you so much for joining us
thank you so much
thanks brian thanks fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you